we used on to use different tools and a
is to try and push the field forward and
try and do it in lots of different ways
as opposed to just taking one approach
and keep hammering the same or it must
be the same as an evolutionary algorithm
we must do what evolutionary algorithm
people do traditional forty-year-old
technique of crossover and mutation to
optimize some numbers we don't have to
in about 1999 year 2000 researchers
started to see some problems with
negative selection negative selection
cannot scale also because the definition
of normal only happens once if what you
define as normal changes then this
system does not take that into account
false alarms can be problematic for
detection systems so if you hear a house
alarm going off and the same person's
house alarm goes off several times in
one week by the end of the week what
happens you ignore the alarm and what
often happens is then people thoughts
which the security system on well we
find the same from physical security is
mirrored in computer security and if
intrusion detection systems generate too
many false alarms and then computer
users have a nasty habit of switching
them off and thus rendering the computer
unprotected which is a worse state than
we were before we applied anything so
these are two sub scaring the problem
and false positives were also seen as
quite a large problem we went back to
the lab and found out what was new in
immunology to see if it could give us
any insight and what was discovered was
that there was a novel theory in
immunology called the danger theory and
which was questioning this whole self
non-self business and
the researchers decided that to look at
the danger theory in an artificial
immune systems con context was one
really exciting because it was taking
proper cutting-edge recently published
immunology and putting it in a computer
and - it might actually be useful in
reducing the the problem of certainly
the problem of false positives as
biological experiments had shown
explicitly that the the danger theory
was designed to augment the system of
self and non-self in order to be able to
relieve this problem so a number of us
worked on using the danger theory in
artificial immune systems for a number
of years and in conjunction with my
supervisor at the time we came up with a
novel algorithm called the dendritic
cell algorithm which is based on the
principles of danger theory and it
receives something called the death
signal so the danger theory states that
the human immune system doesn't really
get activated unless there is evidence
of damage and we found this a really
really appealing idea for computer
security and what we've done is we've
turned this into into a workable
algorithm which again has been applied
to a range of problems in computer
security and at its heart this algorithm
copies the behavior of a cell called the
dendritic cell which is the cell
responsible in the body for processing
danger signals so the information
gathered by dendritic cells is then
passed on to the T cells of the human
immune system which are then instructed
how to behave so it's the instructions
given to them through this danger
sensitive system which actually
determines whether an immune response is
initiated on art and so by taking that
cutting-edge immunology by building on
what we'd already learned with negative
selection we're able to build an
algorithm which works in there to real
time which is very computationally
efficient and also produces hide
action rates on a number of different
problems this algorithm has now been
formally characterized and formally
verifies and has been applied to quite a
wide range of problems both in and out
of computer security is it open source
or anything
registered yeah it's um there's a number
of large multinational companies who
have incorporated into various systems
unfortunately I wasn't directly involved
so I didn't get loads of money off it
but reporting denies it all yeah sure
I've got to remember to take the rude
comments out of my code now ah I have a
very clean version in Haskell but that
relies on people into staffing Haskell
so why do you ask for it is that you
over here hmm and it's the work I did
last summer and because we wanted to get
a really really clear specification for
it and we found that using functional
approach allowed us to describe it in
really unique ways so that's a language
you normally use them know so now that
we've got this proofing in Haskell now
got this implementation in Haskell we
can formally reason about the algorithm
to much greater depth than what we did
before that's the most excited you
looked yeah it's great because the other
stuff I guess I mean I find it I find it
really amazing and it is really amazing
um but it's a bit old for me now whereas
that's really that's really new and to
me real exciting a new trend within
artificial immune systems is for us
computer scientists give something back
you have something back to those
immunologists who work so tirelessly in
the lab to get these models that we
shamelessly exploit and there's been a
shift in a is towards more modeling of
the human immune system for medical
purposes and for clinical purposes
rather than just for the purpose of
creating better computing tools so
there's a whole stream of research now
within artificial immune systems which
is involved in
and computational immunology so building
computer models of what the human immune
system does so how it reacts what
different cell types do and also more
interestingly how we can then build
these models and manipulate the models
to give us insight as to how we might
deal with diseases like cancer so so
this is a really hot topic within
artificial immune systems and this is
something that we're seeing more and
more of as the years go on and as our
simulation and modeling tools get better
and also as our computing platforms get
more powerful we're moving towards the
point where we're potentially able to
make a model of an immune system which
is currently a little bit out of reach
but is something that I hope we'll reach
within the next decade so I think that's
really really quite exciting also in
terms of artificial immune systems it's
a really exciting time in terms of
application because we're seeing all
these new computing platforms emerging
in terms of smartphones which weren't
around five years ago how did we best
protect people using online banking
systems and also how do we protect how
do we protect people using novel devices
like Google glass be really interesting
if your Google glass got some thoughts
sort of virus and was feeding you wrong
information so if you have your immune
system on there telling you whether
that's valid on our so these new
platforms pose new challenges for all
computer scientists but do suppose us
some really quite interesting challenges
in artificial mean systems hit the
hardware reset button so one of the
problems there is that we'd written to
memory locations have belonged to
something else in this case it was the
operating system this leaves us with
attuned population detectors which only
detect things that we have defined as
not normal because it's not in our
definition of normal